The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to spend a
little bit of time today
finishing up what we were
saying last time, about
orthonormal expansions.
Just, essentially, to get a
better understanding of what
it means to go from finite
dimension to infinite dimension.
For the most part, you can just
ignore the question of
being at an infinite dimensional
space, and
everything is pretty much the
same as it is in finite
dimensions.
But there are a few things
you have to be a
little careful about.
So, let's suppose that we have
a set of orthonormal vectors.
Like the sinc vectors for
example, that we were using
for the sinc functions that we
were using, to talk about the
Fourier series.
And the thing that we said last
time at the end of the
hour, we quoted this theorem
which was almost obvious, I
think, in terms of the other
things that we did.
Which said that if you start
out with some vector v, you
can project it successively onto
the set of orthonormal
functions in such a way that you
get closer and closer to
the vector that you're
looking for.
And the theorem that we had was
that the projection on the
whole space, which we call u,
in fact is the same as the
limit of this sum of orthonormal
functions as we
take the limit adding more and
more functions into this sum.
So this was sort of the same
kind of thing that we were
doing when we were going --
it's the same sort of thing that
we did when we were doing
the projection theorem for
finite dimensions.
You remember the thing that we
did there was to first project
this function onto a
single waveform.
Then we found the part of the
waveform that was orthogonal
to the first waveform.
That gave us our second
waveform.
And the thing that we're doing
here, which is sort of
different, is we're starting
out with the orthogonal
sequence to start with.
Anyway, the thing that we showed
was that the vector we
start with, minus this
approximation, which is in the
space generated by all of these
p sub n's, that this
difference has to be orthogonal
to each p sub n.
Because that was a way
we constructed it.
So this difference is -- well,
the limit goes to zero, but
also the difference is
orthogonal to each phi sub x.
This is the thing which is new,
which we didn't get from
looking at the Fourier series.
We could have gotten it from
looking at the Fourier series,
but this is the thing which is
general for every orthonormal
expansion in the world.
Not just a Fourier series,
except all of them.
And then we say that an inner
product space has accountably
infinite dimension.
If accountably infinite set of
orthonormal vectors exist,
such that only the
zero vectors are
orthogonal to each other.
This comes back to one of the
issues that we faced when we
were going through the
Fourier series.
Namely, we showed all this nice
stuff, which was really
about approximating a waveform
by the Fourier series.
The thing that we never showed,
and the thing which is
messy and difficult, is that
if you take a time-limited
function and expand it in a
Fourier series, how do you
know that when you get all done,
you're actually going to
get the function back again?
This is the part of it which
we never talked about.
We talked about how you generate
all of the Fourier
coefficients, and all
of that was fine.
And we showed that when you
were all done, this
representation function that you
had was in fact orthogonal
the thing that was left over.
But you never showed that
the thing that was left
over went to 0.
And the thing this is saying
is you don't have to worry
about that too much.
Because the thing which is left
over has to be orthogonal
to everything you
started with.
And this sum here has
to go to some limit.
What is this limit in the case
of the Fourier series?
Suppose we start out with an
arbitrary L2 function.
We now try to expand that
arbitrary L2 function in a
Fourier series from minus t
over 2 to plus t over 2.
And we can do that.
When we're all done, this series
here is in fact going
to be the part of the function
which lies between minus t
over 2 and plus t over 2.
And this difference here -- well
v minus u, the difference
between the original vector and
this representation vector
is going to be this part of
the function which lies
outside of minus t over
2 to plus t over 2.
So the next thing that we did
then was to show that the
truncated sinusoids and the sinc
weighted sinusoids both
in fact span L2.
In other words, any function in
L2, after you represent it
in terms of that series, what
you have left over has to be
orthogonal.
In other words, if you take this
entire set of truncated
sinusoids, every non-zero
function is
orthogonal to all of that.
Every non-zero function in
this L2 equivalent sense.
So in fact, the thing you get
out of this is this part of
looking at functions which
we always ignored.
There's another issue that we
ignored, when we were looking
at functions, which
comes out of this.
Since v, by assumption
is an L2 vector.
In other words, it's an L2
function aside from this L2
equivalent stuff, and phi sub
m is an L2 vector also, this
inner product has to be
finite, by the Schwarz
inequality.
How did we get around this when
we were dealing with the
Fourier series?
Does anybody remember?
Of course you don't remember.
I hardly remembered that.
The way we got around it
was by saying that this
orthonormal function which was
in a truncated sinusoid.
It was truncated to minus t over
2 and plus t over 2, and
the waveform was just
e to the i 2 pi f t.
The magnitude of that function
was always less
than or equal to 1.
And because the magnitude was
always less than or equal to
1, you could just take the
integral of v of t times phi
sub n of t, and you could show
directly that that integral
always existed.
Because of the special property
of the sinusoids.
Here what we're saying is,
you don't have to worry
about that any more.
You can use arbitrary L2
functions as the components of
an L2 orthonormal expansion.
And it still works.
So every one of these things
has to be finite also.
So, in fact we're buying
something out of this.
At the end of the notes on
Lectures Eight to Ten, you
will notice something that I'm
certainly not going to hold
you responsible for.
Something called the prolate
spiroidal expansion.
And it's just given there
primarily as one more example
of an orthonormal expansion.
It's a very interesting
orthonormal expansion because
it has the property that if you
start out asking how much
energy can I concentrate within
a fixed time interval,
and a fixed bandwidth
interval.
Which is one of the things which
make this whole subject
a little bit fishy
in a whole and
certainly very, very messy.
If I start out with a time
limited function and go
through the Fourier series,
these truncated sinusoids
spill their energy out of
the band enormously.
In fact, one of the problems at
the end of Lectures Eight
to Ten carries you through the
process of just how much
energy you can have outside
of band by using
these truncated sinusoids.
Because truncated sinusoids,
when you look at them in a
Fourier series, have a lot
of energy outside of
where it should be.
So that this particular set of
prolate spiroidal functions
gives you the answer to the
following question.
I would like to find that
function, which is limited to
minus t over 2 plus t over 2,
which has the largest amount
of energy, largest fraction of
its energy, within the band
minus w to plus w.
What is that function?
Well, that function happens to
be the zero order prolate
spheroidal function.
It's the nice property
that it has.
And it's a nice function, which
almost looks like a
rectangular function.
But it just trails off to 0.
And I say, OK, if I want to
construct an orthonormal
expansion, and I want to find
another function which is
orthogonal to that function
and has the next biggest
amount fraction of its energy,
inside of this -- strictly
inside of this time limit, and
as much of the energy within
the frequency limit
as possible,
what's that next function?
Well, you solve that problem.
If you're very good at
interval equations.
And I certainly couldn't
solve it.
But, anyway, it has
been solved.
I mean, physicists for a long
time have worried about that
particular kind of question.
Because it comes up in
physics all the time.
If you time-limit something
and you take the Fourier
integral, how can you also come
as close to frequency
limiting as possible?
So this particular prolate
spheroidal set of orthogonal
functions, in fact, exactly
solves the problem of how do
you generate a set of
orthonormal functions which in
fact have as much energy
as possible both
frequency-limited and
time-limited?
And what you find when you do
that is, when you take 2 w t
of them, at that point the
energy in these orthonormal
functions, the part of it that's
inside the band, really
starts to cut off very,
very sharply,
when w and t are large.
So that in fact you get 2 w t of
these functions, which have
almost all of their energy
in this band.
And everything else has almost
no energy in the band.
So if you ever get interested
in the question of how many
waveforms really are there,
which are concentrated in time
and frequency, that's the
answer to the problem.
And don't bother to read it now,
but just remember that if
you ever get interested in that
problem, which I'm sure
you will at some point or
other, that's where the
solution lies.
And I hope I gave a reference
to it there.
I think I did.
Anyway, we have these functions
which span L2.
And there's at least one
other orthonormal
expansion that we have.
Which is both time- and
frequency-limited.
And either at the end of today
or at the beginning of Monday,
we're going to find another
particularly important
sequence of orthonormal
functions.
Which we actually use when
we're transmitting data.
So to give an example of what
we were just talking about,
the Fourier series functions
span the space of functions
over minus t over
2 to t over 2.
And when normalized, these
functions become 1 over the
square root of t times what
we started with before.
Namely, a sinusoid truncated.
Before we were dealing with
the orthogonal functions
without the 1 over square
root of t in it.
If you want to make them
orthonormal, you get this
square root of 1 over t, because
when you take the
energy in this function,
you get t.
If you don't believe me, set k
equal to 0 and look at that.
And even I can integrate that.
And when you integrate 1 from
minus t over 2 to t
over 2, you get 1.
So, then you have to multiply
by the square
root of 1 over t.
When you view the Fourier series
functions in this way,
it's nice because they're
orthonormal.
It's not nice because the
square root of 1 over t
appears everyplace.
But the nice thing about it is
that then when you expand in
the Fourier series, you don't
find this t anywhere.
Namely, v is equal to the limit
of these approximations
where the n'th approximation is
just the sum from minus m
to m of alpha sub k. phi sub k
and alpha sub k is just this
inner product.
So, again, you got something
nicer by looking at these
things in terms of vectors You
get nice statements about how
these things converge, and you
also get a very compact way of
writing out what the
expressions are.
You also get something a little
bit fishy, which a lot
of people in the communication
field, especially ones who do
theoretical work, run
into problems with.
And the problem is the
following: when you start
dealing all the time with
vectors, and you forget about
the underlying functions and the
underlying integrals, you
start to think that the
subject is simpler
than it really is.
Because you forget about all
the limiting issues.
And when you forget about all
the limiting issues, it's fine
almost all the time.
But every once in a while,
you get trapped.
And when you get trapped, you
then have to go back behind
all of the vector stuff and you
have to start looking at
these integrals again and it
gets rather frustrating.
So you ought to keep both
of these things in mind.
Let's go on, let's get back from
mathematics into worrying
about the question of how
do you send data over
communication channels.
And this is just a picture that
we saw starting on Day
One of this course, which says
the usual way of doing this
is, you start out with --
you start out with the source.
You break the source down into
binary data, and then you take
the binary data and you transmit
it over a channel.
And this is the picture of
what you get when you're
trying to transmit binary
data over a channel.
And here, we've broken down the
encoder, as we called it,
into two pieces.
One of which we call the
discrete encoder and one of
which we call modulation.
Now, this is a little
bit fishy also.
Because there are a lot of
people who now talk about
coded modulation, where it
turns out to be nice to
combine this discrete encoder
with the modulation function.
And when you actually build
modern-day full encoder,
namely the whole thing from
binary digits to what goes out
on the channel, you very
often combine these
two functions together.
What is it that allows
people to do that?
The fact that they first studied
how to do it when they
separate the problems into
two separate problems.
And when you separate the two
problems, what we wind up with
is binary digits coming in.
You massage those binary digits
strictly digitally.
And what comes out is a
sequence of symbols.
And, usually, the sequence of
symbols comes out at a slower
rate, and the binary
digits come in.
For example, if you take two
binary digits and you convert
them into one symbol, from a
symbol alphabet with force of
size four, then for every
two in you get one out.
If you take three binary digits
coming in, then you
need a symbol alphabet
of size eight here.
If you move down in rate from
four binary digits to one
symbol, then of course you need
an alphabet of size 16.
So the size of the alphabet
here is going up
exponentially, as the great
advantage that you get is
going down.
We will talk about that
more as we move on.
You should sort of keep in mind
that there's a strange
relationship between size of
alphabet and the rate at which
you can transmit.
As you try to transmit at higher
and higher rates here,
the size of your alphabet goes
up exponentially, with the
rate gain that you get.
In fact, when you look at
Shannon's famous formula of
how fast you can communicate
on a channel, you find a
logarithm of a signal
to noise ratio.
Of 1 plus a signal
When you look at that signal to
noise ratio and you look at
this alphabet size in here, you
can almost see just from
that why in fact that
logarithm in
these capacity formulas.
And we'll come back
to talk about that
again more later also.
But, anyway, what we're going
to do at this point is to
separate this into the problem
of discrete encoding and
modulation.
And in modulation, you start
out with some arbitrary
alphabet of symbols.
You turn the symbols in that
alphabet into waveforms.
You transmit the waveforms.
You then get the symbol back,
and then you put it into a
digital encoder, which gets
the binary digits back.
Now, what order are we going
to study these in?
Well, we're going to study
the modulation first.
And we're not going to study
this at all, essentially,
except for a few very, very
simple-minded examples.
6.451, which is the course that
follows after this, which
might or might not be taught
in the Spring term, and
incidentally those of you who
want it to be taught should
send me an email saying you
really need to take this next
term for some reason or other.
Because otherwise it will be
given in Spring of the
following year instead of
Spring of this year.
There's another side to that
issue, which is a wireless
course is going to be given in
the Spring of this year.
And if you want to take a
wireless course and postpone
taking the coding course until
the following year, then in
fact it might be better to
do the postponing job.
I would recommend that those of
you who are interested in
wireless take the course now.
Because if you're looking for
research problems in a
communication area, wireless is
probably the hottest area
around, and the area
where the most
interesting problems occur.
So, you have to make
that tradeoff.
If you want to take both
of the courses, great.
Send me an email and
say you want to
take the coding course.
But anyway, there'll be very
little coding in this course,
very little discrete coding.
And mostly we're going to look
at simple ways of taking
simple symbol sequences, turning
them into waveforms
and then transmitting
them on channels.
AUDIENCE: So, basically, when
you do the source coding, you
have to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
binary --
PROFESSOR: Binary to
symbol to waveform.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, why don't I go
from waveforms directly to
waveforms instead of going from
waveforms to symbols to
binary digits, and then I just
have to go back up again.
A bunch of reasons.
One of the reasons is that some
of the stuff that you
transmit is already digital
to start with.
When you look at what goes
over a network today, for
example, it's carrying
digital data, it's
carrying analog data.
It's carrying images.
It's carrying everything
you can imagine.
If you want to design a
modulation system which goes
directly from analog data to
channel data, and you have a
hundred different kinds of
analog source data, and you
have a hundred different kinds
of channels, then you're going
to have to build one encoder
for every combination of
source and channel.
In other words, you've got to
built ten thousand devices.
If your interest is in keeping
engineers employed, which I
think is a very good interest,
that's a very good
philosophy to take.
But, unfortunately, most people
who build communication
equipment say, we would really
rather have just a hundred --
well, two hundred different
devices.
One hundred devices which turn
all these different sources
into binary digits, and another
hundred devices which
turn the binary digits into
something that can be
transmitted over any channel
you want to.
I mean, this is just a
general example of
what people call layering.
You want to turn systems into
systems with a bunch of layers
in them, where each layer is
standardized in some way.
And only has to take care of
a few particular functions.
And, in fact, that's what
we're doing here also.
Because we're dealing with
one layer, which is
doing discrete encoding.
Which in fact is sort of
generating, for the most part,
binary digits out of the
discrete encoder.
Where, as you go through all of
this stuff and you come out
with binary digits, some of
which are wrong, you can do
the decoding and get the correct
binary digits out.
If you look at an awful lot of
coding theory, you'll find out
it doesn't pay any attention at
all to what's going on in
the channel.
Lots of people who've studied
coding all of their lives, and
decoding all of their lives,
live in this mathematical
theory of abstract algebra.
And they have no idea of
what channels are.
And they survive because of
this layering principle.
So if you want to employ
engineers, it's nice to have
layering also.
Because engineers don't have
to know as much then.
Of course, you people
should know it all.
So because, then you
can do anything.
And you can be part of those
very rare people who can put
it all together.
I was just at the 70th birthday
party of Irwin Jacobs
this past week.
And Irwin Jacobs is the CEO of
Qualcomm, which is the company
that started to build CDMA
wireless systems.
For a long time, the CDMA
systems were thought of as
probably better than TDMA and
FDMA, but much more expensive.
And eventually, we're in the
situation where all the new
systems being designed
are all using CMDA.
As a result of this,
Irwin Jacobs is a
very wealthy person.
We went to a symphony Friday
night, out in San Diego, which
was given specifically
for him.
Partly because he'd just
given $110 million to
the San Diego Symphony.
So you can figure from that
that he's fairly wealthy.
Well the point of all of that
is, he started out as a
faculty member here.
He was one of the authors of
Rosencraft and Jacobs, which
is sort of the Bible of digital
communications systems
from the `60s.
And people still use it, it's
still an excellent book.
And in doing that, he really
learned the communication
trade from soup to --
I guess, soup to nuts is
the way we put it now.
And he could do the
whole thing.
And because he could do the
whole thing, because he
understood coding, because he
understood modulation, because
he understood channels, this is
why he could design systems
that really work.
I was talking to the Chief
Technology Officer out there,
and the Chief Technology Officer
said his job was
really very easy because Irwin
did all of that himself.
And he still does it.
So it really makes sense to know
something about all of
these pieces.
If you want to become
a billionaire.
And if you want to become a
billionaire without cheating.
Now, many people become
billionaires by cheating, and
you've heard of many
of them but.
Well, anyway.
Enough of that.
I mean, none of us really want
to be billionaires anyway, --
I mean, there's nothing you
can do with more than a
billion dollars, right?
It's all wasted.
Let's move on.
We've gotten rid of digital
coding, saying we're not going
to deal with that here.
Let me take the PAM out of here
because I don't want to
even say what it is yet.
If we take this box I called
modulation before, which was
one of the two main pieces of
a channel encoder, we can
break it down into two pieces.
Namely, mainly we're going to
be layering things again.
We start out with this symbol
sequence, which is what comes
out of the encoder, which is
usually just a short sequence
of binary digits.
So the symbols can be thought
of as two binary digits in a
sequence, or four binary digits,
or six tuples of
binary digits, or
what have you.
And all of those are common.
There's then a signal
consolation that turns symbols
into signals.
Now, notation in the field is
totally non-uniform, because
most people use symbols and
sequences and waveforms and
binary n-tuples, all totally
synonymously.
And the distinction we'll try
to make here is that symbols
are things like binary digits,
that don't have any numerical
meaning to them.
I mean, a 1 and a 0, the only
thing important there is that
1 and 0 are different
from each other.
All computer scientists call
1 and 0's Alices and Bobs.
Lots of other people
call them plus-1's.
and minus 1's.
Doesn't make any difference
what you'd call them, it's
just an alphabet with
two values in it.
When we talk about signals,
we're talking
about numerical values.
So in fact, you could have a
signal constellation with two
elements in it, where what
you're doing is mapping 1 and
0 into plus 1 and minus 1.
Now, that's a pretty silly
kind of situation, but it
still has the value of saying,
you're turning things where
there's just an alphabeticized
2 into something where you're
saying, these are numerical
values and you're interested
in the difference between
the numerical values.
And the difference is measured
in the ordinary way of
measuring difference for
numerical values.
Or, these can be vectors also.
But vectors in an inner product
space where, again,
you have length.
And you have distance.
So you have numerical
values here.
You don't have numerical
So we're going to talk about
how you do this.
And then, for the most part,
we're going to define
modulation as what happens when
you go from the signal
sequence to the waveform.
You might realize that our
notation is lousy here.
Because I'm calling modulation
this whole thing.
And I'm also calling modulation
just this thing.
And I'm doing that because there
doesn't seem to be any
other reasonable word for either
one of these things.
So, and I'm going to
later split this
into two pieces also.
But that will come later.
So, anyway, we're going
from symbols
to signals to waveforms.
Which might look remarkably
similar to
what we did with sources.
But we just did it backwards
with sources.
We went from waveforms to
signals to symbols there.
And here we're doing
the same thing.
The modulator often converts a
signal sequence to a baseband
waveform, and then converts
the baseband waveform to a
passband waveform.
And, just historically, people
used to think of modulation as
the process of taking something
at baseband and
converting it up to
some passband.
Now it's recognized that the
interesting problem is not,
how do you go from baseband
to passband.
Which is just multiplying by
cosine wave, not much more to
it than that.
Well, it's a little more
to it, but not much.
And the interesting problem is,
how do you convert signals
into waveforms.
Which is why we went, one of
the reasons we went through
all of this stuff about L2
waveforms and orthonormal
expansions and all
of this stuff.
So, for the time being, we're
going to look at modulation
and demodulation, without
worrying about what bandwidth
any of this occurs at.
So we'll just look at
it at baseband.
So the simplest example of all
of this, so simple that it
almost looks like it's silly, is
to map a sequence of binary
digits into a sequence of
signals from the constellation
1 and minus 1.
So all you're doing there is
mapping 0 into 1 and mapping 1
into minus 1.
In other words, the 0 and 1
binary digits are mapped into
1 and minus 1.
Why do you do it this way, which
is a little confusing,
mapping 0 into 1 instead
of mapping 1 into 1?
Well, primarily, so you can
look at multiplication of
signals in the same way as you
look at modular to addition of
binary digits.
It just turns out to
be a little more
convenient that way.
And it doesn't make a whole
lot of difference.
The point is, we're going from
0 1's to signals which are 1
and minus 1.
Then this sequence of signals
is mapped into a waveform
which is the sum of u of k times
the sinc function t over
capital T minus k.
In other words, you're thinking
of each one of these
signals, now, think of it as
being a sum of impulses,
delayed impulses.
And then think of taking a
little sinc, sinc t over t and
putting it around each one
of those impulses.
In other words, think of
passing each of those
impulses, which is weighted by
one of these values, u sub k,
into a linear filter whose
response is sine of x over x.
Anybody
see anything a little bit
fishy about that?
Have you ever built a filter
whose response
was sine x over x?
AUDIENCE: It's hard to.
PROFESSOR: It's hard to, why?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because it's
not causal, yes.
We're going to talk about
that more later today.
Communication engineers hardly
ever talk about causality.
They hardly ever talk about
whether something
is realized or not.
And the reason I want to say
this a number of times is that
one of the parts of
any receiver is a
timing recovery circuit.
And what the timing recovery
circuit does is, it tries to
figure out what the transmitter
timing is, in
terms of what it's receiving.
And when you're figuring out
what the transmitter timing is
in terms of what you're
receiving, the most convenient
way of doing that, if you're
sending a pulse or something,
you would like the receiver
timing to peak up at the same
time that the transmitter timing
is peaking up, in terms
of the pulse.
In other words, you want to
get rid of the propagation
delay and just ignore that.
The receiver timing is going
to be delayed from the
transmitter timing exactly
by the propagation delay.
Now, if we always do that,
causality becomes totally
unimportant.
Now, one of the problems with a
sinc function is, it starts
at time minus infinity.
And even if you delay the
receiver timing by an infinite
amount of time you can never use
the communications system
until it's time to tear it down
and bring in a new one.
Which, unfortunately, is what
happened to the third
generation wireless systems.
By the time, people figured
out how to build them,
everybody was saying, ah,
old-fashioned stuff, we're
going to go directly onto
to fourth generation.
And they might go directly
from fourth generation to
fifth generation.
Who knows.
Anyway, you can't implement
these even with the receiver
timing different than the
transmitter timing.
But you can always approximate
things with enough delay
between transmitter
and receiver.
So that you can approximate
any filter you want to,
without worrying about
causality at all.
And it's hard enough designing
good filters without worrying
about casuality that you don't
want to bring that into your
picture at the beginning.
So communication engineers
usually say that those timing
issues are not important.
And a little bit of delay is
not going to hurt anything.
All of Shannon's theory was as
successful as it has been, and
transformed the whole
communication industry,
because he never talked
about delay at all.
He just ignored the question
of delay from
beginning to end.
And when you look at his
capacity formulas, they are
assuming that you have as much
delay as you need between
transmitter and receiver.
And, assuming that that isn't
important, and in terms of the
propagation delays, and the
filtering delays in most
modern communication systems,
those delays
are not really important.
The propagation delays
you can't avoid.
So you might as well
ignore them.
Which is why you build timing
recovery circuits.
And the filtering delays are
usually unimportant.
Relative to all of the
other delays that
come into these system.
So for the most part,
we're just going to
ignore those questions.
If you have no noise, no delay,
and no attenuation, the
received waveform is going
to be the same as
the transmitted waveform.
And then what you would like
to do is to sample that and
convert it back to binary.
So, that's what the receiving
side of this
trivial system is doing.
Now, why can you ignore
attenuation?
Anybody have any idea why
we might want to ignore
attenuation?
Well, it's like all of
these other things.
You don't ignore it, but the
question you ask is, can I
separate the issue of
attentuation from the other
issues that I want
to look at now.
In other words, can I layer
this problem in such a way
that we can deal with our
problems one by one.
And the problem of attentuation
is something that
communication engineers have had
to deal with from day one.
In dealing with it from day one,
they have dealt with all
of the different ways of losing
power that you have.
Which includes attenuation in
the actual medium between
transmitter and receiver.
It deals with the attenuation
you get in the receiver by
building filters and by all the
other things you do there.
When you get all done with that,
there's only one thing
that's important.
Because you can deal digitally
with very, very small signals.
And the only thing that's
important is what
happens to the noise.
You get noise in the
communication medium.
That comes into the receiver.
And now, any time you amplify
what you receive, they're
going to be amplifying the noise
as well as amplifying
the signal.
An easy way to deal with that is
to assume that there isn't
any attentuation in what you're
calling the signal,
because you're going to amplify
that to a reasonable
value to operate on it anyway.
So in fact you're amplifying
the noise.
So the only thing you're
interested in is, what's the
ratio between the signal power
and the noise power.
So, those issues, we can deal
with completely separately
from these issues of what
kind of waveforms
do we want to choose.
What should we choose in place
of this sinc function, which
is impractical because it causes
too much delay and it's
also hard to build
the filters.
So we'd like to deal with that
question separately from the
question of attenuation.
There's a short section in the
notes, which I'm not going to
go into, because you can read
it just as easily as I can
talk about it, about dB.
And why people use dB to talk
about all of these questions
of energy losses.
And why, in fact, there's a
whole set of engineers whose
function is to deal
with link budgets.
In other words, when you build
a communications system,
you're losing power everywhere
along the way.
You're losing it
in the median.
You're losing it by the way
you build the antennas.
You're losing some here, you're
losing some there.
And what these people do is,
they look at all of these
attenuations together.
And they multiply together.
So, in fact, it's easier to take
the logarithm of all of
these terms.
And when you take the logarithm,
that's where you
get decibels from.
Because these people, instead of
taking natural logs, which
would seem like a much more
reasonable thing, always take
the logarithm to the base 10
and then divide by 10.
And what the section in the
notes says is that that's a
practice which has grown up
because it's very easy to do
mental arithmetic with that.
The logarithm to the base 10 of
the number 2 which is one
of the biggest numbers
that ever appears.
2's are more important
than thousands, OK?
And the logarithm to the
base 2 of 10 is 0.3.
And when you divide it
by 10 you get 3 dB.
So a factor of 2
is called 3 dB.
This means that a factor of 4,
which is 2 squared, is 6 dB.
Factor of 8 is 9 dB,
and so forth.
And this gives this table of
all these numbers which all
communication engineers
memorize.
The other reason for it is that
if you're talking to a
communication engineer, he will
recognize you as a member
of his fraternity if
you let the word dB
slip several times.
Don't even have to know
what it means.
You just talk about dB.
And you say, my income is 3
dB lower than your income.
And that makes him very happy.
So.
Anyway.
That's all we need for
this simple example.
We now want to go into more
complicated things.
OK pulse amplitude
and modulation.
This is one of the major ways of
turning bits into signals,
and then turning the signals
into waveforms again.
Again, I'm doing this first
not because it's the most
important scheme to talk about,
but because we want to
understand these things
one by one.
And when we understand PAM,
we'll then talk about QAM.
And you'll understand that.
And then we can go on
to look at other
variations of these things.
So the signals in PAM
are one dimensional.
The constellation, the only
thing it can be, since it's
one dimensional, one
real dimension, is
a set of real numbers.
So you're going to modulate
these real numbers.
And that, we're going
to talk about later.
How do you find this
function here?
We're just going to take these
real numbers, which are coming
into the transmitter
one by one out
of the digital encoder.
You're going to take
these numbers.
You're going to view them as
being multiplied by delayed
impulses, and then pass
through a filter.
And the filter's response is
just, impulse response is
just, p of t.
In other words, what we're doing
is saying, we don't like
the sinc function.
Therefore, simplest thing to
do is replace the sinc
function by something
we do like.
So we're going to replace the
sinc function by some filter
characteristic, which we like.
And that's the way to modify
this previous example into
something that makes
better sense.
So we're doing two things here
when we're talking about PAM.
One, we're talking about
generalizing this binary
signal set.
And, two, we're talking about
generalizing the sinc function
into some arbitrary
impulse response.
So a standard PAM signal set
uses equispaced signals
symmetric around 0.
And if you look at the picture,
it makes it clear
what this means.
It's the same thing that we were
using all along when we
were talking about
quantization.
If you're looking at one
dimensional quantization,
that's a very natural
way to choose the
representation points.
Here, we're doing everything
in the opposite way.
So we're starting out
with these points.
Well, we're starting out with
eight symbols and turning them
into eight signals.
And when you take eight symbols
and turn them into
eight signals, perfectly natural
thing to do is to make
each of these signals equispaced
from each other,
and center them on the origin.
This is not something we
have to see later.
I think you can see that if
these symbols all are used
with equal probability, and
you're trying to reduce the
amount of energy that the
signals use, which will then
go through into reducing the
amount of energy in the
waveforms that we're
transmitting, it's nice to
have them centered around 0.
Because if they have a mean,
that mean is just going to
contribute directly to the
expected mean square value of
the signal that you're using.
So why not center it around 0.
Later on we'll see many
reasons for not
centering it around 0.
But for now we're not going to
worry about any of those, and
we're going to center
it around 0.
And the other thing is,
why do you want them
to be equally spaced?
Well, I'll talk about that
in just a second.
Anyway, the signal energy in
these equally spaced signals,
you can calculate it to be d
squared times m squared minus
1 divided by 12.
I think we sort of did this when
we were worrying about
quantization.
There's a problem at the end
of lectures 11 and 12 which
guides you by the hand in
how to calculate this.
Or you can sit down and just
calculate it by hand, it's not
hard to do.
But, anyway, that's the mean
square value of these signals.
If you assume that they're
equiprobable.
Now, if you take m to be 2 to
the b, now what's b? b is the
number of binary digits which
come into this signal former
when you produce
one signal out.
Namely, if you bring in b binary
digits, you need an
alphabet of size 2 to the b.
If you have an alphabet of size
2 to b, then you're going
to need m equals 2 to the
b different signals.
So, usually when you have a
standard PAM system, that
number there, 8 PAM,
means 8 signals.
8 is usually going to be
replaced by 4, or 16, or 32,
or 64, or what have you.
And, usually, not
anything else.
Because you're usually going to
deal with something which
is a power of 2.
Because the logarithm of this to
the base 2 is the number of
bits which are coming into the
signal former for each signal
that comes out.
This goes up very rapidly
as m squared goes up.
In other words, you try to
transmit data faster by
bringing more and more bits in
per signal that you transmit,
it's a losing proposition
very, very quickly.
It's this business of a
logarithm which comes into
everything here.
We're going to talk
about noise later.
We're not going to talk
about it now.
But, we have to recognize the
existence of noise enough to
realize that when you look at
this diagram here, when you
look at generating a waveform
around this, or a waveform
around this, however you receive
these things, noise is
going to corrupt what you
receive here by a little bit.
Usually it's Gaussian,
which means it tails
off very, very quickly.
With larger amplitudes.
And what that means is, when
you send a three, the most
likely thing to happen is
that you're going to
detect a three again.
The next most likely thing
is you'll detect
either a four or a two.
In other words, what's important
here is this
distance here.
And hardly anything else.
If you send these signals with
equal probability, and the
noise is additive, the noise
does the same thing no matter
where you are along here.
Which says that this standard
PAM set is almost the only
thing you want to look at.
So long as you assume that the
noise is going to be additive.
And the noise is going to affect
everything along this
line equally.
It says that you just want to
make the spacing between
points big enough that it will
pretty much avoid the noise.
So, the point of all of
that is that d is
fixed, ahead of time.
You can't play with that.
You can play with m.
When you play with m,
you're playing a
losing game with energy.
So that's why standard PAM
is the thing which
is used with PAM.
Not much you can do about it.
And say here that the noise is
independent of the signal.
We will talk about this later.
The noise being additive.
The noise being independent of
the signal are both saying
almost the same thing.
Which will be obvious to
you in a little while.
But not until we start
talking about noise.
We don't want to start talking
about noise now.
So, for now, we deal with the
noise just by saying that
every signal must be separated
by some minimum amount.
Again, what we said about
delay and attenuation.
Let me say it again, because
it's important enough that you
have to understand it.
After you go through two or
three problem sets, you will
not understand it again.
Because you'll get so used to
dealing the receive signal as
the same as the transmitted
signal that you'll forget the
weirdness in that.
I mean, people become accustomed
to extraordinarily
weird things very,
very easily.
And especially when you're
taking a course and trying to
get the problems done, you just
take things which are
totally ridiculous and accept
them if it lets you get
through the problem set.
So I want to tell you right up
front that there is some
weirdness associated here.
It is something you have
to think about.
After you think about it once,
you then accept this is a
layering decision.
You ignore delay, since the
timing recovery locks the
receiver clock to the
transmitter clock plus the
propagation delay.
And in fact, it can lock the
receive clock to any place
that wants to lock it to.
So we're going to lock it in
such a way that the receive
signal looks like the
transmitted signal.
And the attenuation is really
part of the link budget.
We can separate that from all
the things we're going to do.
I mean, if we don't separate
that, you have to go into
antenna design.
And all this other stuff.
And who wants to do that?
I mean, we have enough
to do in this course.
It's pretty full anyway.
So we're just going to scale the
signal and noise together.
And that's a separate issue.
So now we want to look at the
thing which is called PAM
modulation.
In other words, in this one
slide we separated the
question of choosing the signal
constellation, which
we've now solved by saying, we
want to use signals that are
equally spaced.
So that's an easy one.
From the question of, how do
you choose the filter.
So the PAM modulation is going
to go by taking a sequence of
signals, mapping it into a
waveform, which is this
expansion here.
We're not assuming that these
functions are orthogonal to
each other.
Although later, we will find
out that they should be.
But for now, p of t is just
some arbitrary waveform.
And we will try to figure out
how to choose this waveform in
such a way as to replace the
sinc waveform with something
which is better in terms of
delay and almost as good in
all other ways.
We're not going to worry about
the fact that p of t has to be
realizable.
Because with our arbitrary
time reference at the
receiver, it doesn't have
to be realizable.
It doesn't have to be causal.
So, p of t could be
sinc of t over t.
Which would give us a nice
baseband limited function.
But it could be anything
else at all.
As we said before, sinc
t over t a dies out
impractically slowly.
And it requires infinite delay
at the transmitter.
You can't even send these
signals with a
sinc t over t signal.
Because to send them, you have
to start out at the beginning
of this little bit
of wiggling.
Now, you say, OK I'm going
to truncate that
when it's very small.
And I don't worry about that.
The point of what we're starting
to look at now,
though, is we're saying, OK,
you truncate it, you do all
these practical things.
But it turns out that this
problem of choosing this
filter response has
a very elegant
and a very nice solution.
And when we put noise in, it
fits in perfectly with the
idea of also choosing this
filter in a particular way.
Now, we've talked about many
problems here which were
solved almost immediately after
Shannon came out with
his way of looking at
communication in 1948.
Guess when this problem
was solved?
It was solved 20 years earlier
than that by a guy by the name
of Nyquist, who was at
Bell Labs back when
Bell Labs meant something.
I mean, in `28 it was
a great place.
It was a great place until
seven or eight years ago.
Nyquist is important
in feedback theory.
He's done some of the most
important things there.
His Nyquist criterion in dealing
with how do you choose
these filters to avoid
intersymbol interference is
fairly simple.
But it's a very, very
nice result.
So we're going to
talk about it.
And then we will use that to
say, ok, we don't have to
worry about intersymbol
interference any more, so all
we have to worry
about is noise.
So we're getting rid of these
problems one by one.
Our main problem is to choose
this filter, so that we get
some kind of reasonable
compromise between time delay
and bandwidth.
That's -- that's basically the
problem that we're facing.
And Nyquist's solution
to this was to say,
forget about that also.
Let's look at what set of
filters work, and what set of
filters don't work.
And then you can take your
choice among this set of
folders that work.
So our problem is, how do you
take the waveform u of t,
which you receive, and find
these samples out of it?
Now, we already know that if
you use sinc functions, all
you have to do is sample this
and you get these u sub k's
back again.
But if this thing is some
absolutely wild waveform,
maybe that's not what you get.
So we say, OK, how do we
retrieve these signals from
the waveform that was
transmitted and therefore from
the waveform that
was received.
We're separating this from
the noise question.
Even if there's no noise at all,
we still have a question
and how do you find
those input values
directly from the function.
What we're going to do is to
assume that the receiver
filters u of t, with a linear
time invariant filter, with
impulse response q of t.
Now, since we've said that
p of t doesn't have to be
causal, we might as well say
that q of t doesn't have to be
causal either.
Because we've already thrown
these details of
delay to the winds.
So the filtered waveform, then
is going to be r of t.
Will be the integral of what
was transmitted, convolved
with q of t.
So this is what you receive.
And then what we're going to do
is, we're going to sample
this waveform.
So Nyquist said, let's restrict
ourselves to looking
at receivers which first filter
by some filter we're
going to decide on,
and then sample.
Why do you want to do that?
Well, an interesting question.
And Nyquist said, that's
what we're going to do.
And since Nyquist was famous,
that's what we're going to do.
One of the problems in the
homework this week is to show
that if you relax this a little
bit and you say, well,
I don't want to do what Nyquist
said, what I want to
do is to look at an arbitrary
linear receiver which takes
this received waveform, goes
through any old linear
operations that I want
to go through, and
solves for what --
and from that, tries to pick
out these coefficients.
And the question is, can you
do anything more than what
Nyquist did.
And the answer is, no.
If you look at it in another
way, you will find that in
fact, if you know what the
signal constellation is, you
can look at non-linear
receivers.
Which in the absence of noise
will let you pick out these
coefficients in a much
broader context than
what Nyquist said.
And why don't we do that?
Well, because when noise comes
in, that doesn't work at all.
That's a lousy solution.
So what we're going to do is
say, OK, Mr. Nyquist, we'll
play your silly game.
We will have this filter
at the transmitter.
We'll have this filter
at the receiver.
We'll have the sampler and we'll
look at what conditions
we need in order to make
the whole thing work.
And then we will fit it in with
noise and everything.
It will fit in, in
a very nice way.
So we have a nice layered
solution when we do that.
And we will find --
I mean, Nyquist had
some of Shannon's
genes in him, I think.
Because what we find when we're
all finished with this
is that by avoiding -- by being
able to receive these
coefficients perfectly, which
we'll refer to as avoiding
intersymbol interference, it
doesn't hurt us at all as far
as taking care of the noise.
In other words, you can have
your cake and you can eat it
too as far as intersymbol
interference
and noise is concerned.
We wind up with a received
waveform, which is the
integral of the transmitted
waveform times some filter.
And we don't know how to
choose this filter.
But let's just -- this
is a filter.
This can be represented now in
terms of u of t is equal to
this transmitted waveform in
terms of this other filter
that we don't understand.
So we now have two filters
And we have this
integral here.
Well, we can take this sum.
We can bring this sum outside
of the integral and have the
sum of u sub k times, just some
composite filter g of t
where g of t is the
convolution of p
of t and q of t.
Now, when you look at the notes,
the notes are fairly
careful in dealing with all
these questions of L2 and
convergence and all of
this stuff that we've
been talking about.
Again, when you're trying to
understand something for the
first time, ignore all those
mathematical issues.
Try to find out what's
going on.
When you get an intuitive sense
of what's going on, go
back and look at the
mathematics then.
But don't fuss about the
mathematics at this point.
OK, so r of t, then, is just
going to be the sum over k of
these sample values that are
coming in, times this
composite filter, which is the
convolution of the transmit
filter and the recieve filter.
Now, this shouldn't
be surprising.
If you think of u of t as
being formed by taking a
sequence of impulses, and then
passing that sequence of
impulses through a filter p of
t, and then passing the output
through a filter q of t, all
you're doing is passing this
sequence of impulses through
the convolution of p
of t and q of t.
In other words, in terms of
this received waveform, it
couldn't care less what
filtering you do at the
transmitter and what filtering
you do at the receiver.
It's all one big filter as far
as the receiver is concerned.
When we study noise, what
happens with the transmitter
and what happens with
the receiver will
become important again.
But, so far, none of this
makes any difference.
And this is all we need
to worry about.
Then, Nyquist said, a waveform
g of t is ideal Nyquist.
He didn't call it ideal
Nyquist, he
was very modest person.
But since then, people call it
ideal Nyquist because he was
the guy that sorted
it all out.
It's ideal Nyquist with period
t, and I usually leave out the
period t because that's usually
understood, if g of k
t is equal to delta of k.
In other words, if g of 0 is
equal to 1 and g of k times t,
for every non-zero integer
k is equal to 0.
In other words, if g has the
same property that the sine
function has, sine
function is 1.
It's 0.
And it's 0 at every integer
point beyond that.
And Nyquist said, well, gee, all
we need to do is make this
filter has a property.
And when you look at this, it's
fairly obvious that that
works, right?
I mean, we want a
sample RFT --
say, at j times capital T. Or,
if j times capital T, it's
going to be the sum here of u
sub k times g of j t r of t.
r of j t is equal to sum
over k of u k times g
of j t minus k t.
If the waveform is ideal
Nyquist, then this quantity is
0 for all integer k except
when k is equal to j.
So, this is just equal
to u sub j.
And conversely, if this waveform
is not ideal Nyquist,
you have the problem that you
can pick two values. u sub k
and u sub j, in such
a way that they
interfere with each other.
In other words, that they add up
at some sample point to the
wrong value.
One of them is going to come
in and clobber the other.
So, this is a necessary and
sufficient condition for
avoiding intersymbol
interference.
So long as you're not smart
enough to look at what those
actual values are.
In other words, so long as
you're only going to use a
linear receiver, which is
what that amounts to.
While ignoring noise, r of t is
determined by g of t, p of
t and q of t otherwise
irrelevant.
That's what we said.
We said this.
If t of t is ideal Nyquist and
r of k t equals u of k
for all k and z.
If f of t is not ideal Nyquist,
and r f k t unequal
to u k for some k and some
choice of the sequence.
Now, so far there's
no big deal here.
This is pretty easy
to figure out.
You don't need rocket science
to say, once I pose the
problem this why, which
is where part of
Nyquist's genius came from.
The hard thing is always to
post the right problem.
It's not to solve it.
Those of you who want to do Ph.D
theses, believe me, 80%
of the problem is finding
the problem.
20% of the problem
is doing it.
If you do a really outstanding
thesis, 99% is finding the
problem and 1% of
it is doing it.
And I believe that.
I'm not exaggerating.
An ideal Nyquist g of t implies
that no intersymbol
interference occurs at
the above receiver.
In other words, you have a
receiver that actually works.
We're going to see that choosing
g of t to be ideal
Nyquist fits in nicely when
looking at the real problem,
which is coping with both
noise and intersymbol
interference.
And we've also seen that if g of
t is sync of t over capital
T, that works.
It has no intersymbol
interference because that's,
one, at t equals 0, and it's 0
at every other sample point.
We don't like that, because
it has too much delay.
We want to make g of
t strictly baseband
limited to 1 over 2t.
And this turns out to be
the only solution.
And we'll see that in
a little while.
In other words, if you want to
do something which has better
delay characteristics than the
sinc function, your only way
of doing it is spilling out
into slightly higher
frequencies.
So, what Nyquist really wanted
to find out, although you
won't find that out by reading
his paper because it's all
this nice mathematical proof,
is how much do you have to
expand the bandwidth in order to
get nice delay things which
do the same thing.
Well, we think about
it a little bit.
And we have an advantage that
Nyquist didn't have.
Because we understand
about aliasing.
Nyquist didn't understand
Aliasing hadn't been
done at that time.
It was probably done
as a result of
what Nyquist had done.
And if we look at the
reconstruction from the
samples, g of k t of g, we get
this function s of t, which is
the sum of all the samples
times sinc of t
over t, minus k.
That's for an arbitrary
filter.
This baseband reconstruction
by definition, when we were
talking about alising, is
just this function.
We've said that g of t is ideal
Nyquist, if and only if
s of t is equal to sinc
of t over capital t.
Why is that?
You look at this
function here.
You look at s of 0.
And what do you get?
You get the sum of g of
k t times sinc of t
over t minus k.
If we have an ideal Nyquist
filter, then all of these
terms are 0 except when
k is equal to 0.
s of t, in general, if you have
a ideal Nyquist filter,
you only have one
term in here.
So s of t is just equal
to sinc of t over t.
Because all those other
terms go away.
If we take the Fourier transform
of s of t equals
sinc t over capital T, the
Fourier transform is s s tilde
of f is equal to t times
the rectangle
function of f times t.
A sinc function of a Fourier
transform is a rectangle.
And the aliasing theorem then
says that this Fourier
transform of this low pass
representation has to be equal
to this sum of different
frequency terms.
That's what aliasing says.
It says that this baseband
representation is aliased into
by all of these other
frequency bands.
And each of them come in and
add to what you get in
frequency here.
Remember that diagram that we
drew where we took this
arbitrary frequency function and
we picked up what was in
each band, then we stuck it into
the center band and then
we added all these things up?
That's what the aliasing
thing says.
So it says that g of t is ideal
Nyquist if and only if
this sum is equal to that.
And that's the Nyquist
criteria.
That's what Nyquist did.
But he did it long before
anybody had heard of aliasing.
There's a slightly easier way to
look at aliasing criterion,
which now becomes the
Nyquist criterion.
When what you're interested in
is a waveform g of t, which is
almost band-limited
but not quite.
So what we're going to assume
is that it's limited to, at
most, twice this -- this w here
is 1 over 2t, which is
called the Nyquist bandwidth.
Everything is called
Nyquist here, so.
This value here is the minimum
bandwidth you could be using.
It's 1 over capital 2t.
It's what you would get if you
were using the sinc function.
If you were using the sinc
function, what you would get
is something which is
a rectangle here.
Cut off, right at this point.
And cut off right
at this point.
Nyquist is saying, suppose it's
limited to at most 2w.
In other words, suppose you
have a slopover into other
frequencies but, at most into
the next frequency band and no
more than that.
Then, if you look at this thing,
which is spilling out,
and we take the same picture we
were looking at before, we
take this quantity.
Bring it back down here.
We take this quantity,
bring it up here.
And what do we get?
This, added into here.
This thing adds up
right there.
In other words -- well, let's
take this one here.
This thing here gets translated
over to here.
And added to this.
This is assuming that g hat of
f is real, and we're ignoring
the complex part of it.
So this gets added to this.
This is just enough to turn
this into something, which
goes across here
and down here.
Down here.
My finger is not perfect.
But, anyway, when you add this
to this, you get this ideal
rectangular shape.
What this is saying, in terms
of just this upper side band
here, this is going to be the
same as this, from symmetry.
So it's saying, if you take
what's on the positive side of
w, and you rotate it around this
way, you rotate it around
up here, if it's just enough to
fill that in, then you've
satisfied the Nyquist
criteria.
In other words, you want band
edge symmetry here.
You want this to be symmetrical
to this.
In that rotated 180
degree sense.
So it says that anything which
has this band edged symmetry
condition satisfies the property
of no intersymbol
interference.
So this makes the problem
easy for us.
It says, we would like to have
a rectangular function.
That has too much delay, because
in particular the
inverse Fourier transform of
that, because we have a
discontinuity, can drop off,
at most, as 1 over t.
Which is pretty slow.
We've gotten rid of
the discontinuity.
We've also gotten rid of the
slope discontinuity, the way I
drew the figure here.
And, therefore, we can wind up
with a function which decays
as 1 over t cubed.
Which is a whole lot better
than 1 over t.
And, excuse me for going
a little over, but.
The things people build in
practice usually have
something called a raised
cosine filter.
Which is this messy expression
here, for
the frequency response.
But it really isn't that bad.
In fact, it's just
what this is.
This frequency response is t
over most of the frequency
interval, up to 1 over 2t.
It's t times a raised cosine
over this part of the
frequency band here.
t times cosine squared, and the
cosine squared just raises
things up to be average
out at 1/2, and it's
0 everywhere else.
So what you're doing here in
that formula is simply making
things t up to here.
Making it a raised
cosine here.
And making it 0 everywhere
else.
And, depending on what do choose
as alpha, that makes
this sharper or less sharp.
And people usually choose it
to be about, alpha to be
about 15% or so.
Which means these filters chop
off very, very rapidly.
Is that hard to build?
Doesn't make any difference.
I mean, these days, anything
which you can figure out how
to compute, you can put it on
a little chip and it costs
nothing if you make
enough of them.
So you want to raise the cosine
filter which cuts off
at 15%, fine.
Somebody spends a year
designing it.
And then you cookie-cut
it forever after.
So it doesn't cost anything.
And, well, g of t also has an
inverse transform which we
won't worry about.